Pourquoi diable ferait-on ça?
Il y a 12 ans,
j'ai animé un TED talk sur 10 façons pour la Terre de s'éteindre subitement.
Nous sommes incroyablement vulnérables aux caprices de notre propre galaxie.
Un seul, grand astéroïde pourrait nous faire disparaître pour toujours.
Pour survivre, il nous faut explorer au-delà de la Terre-mère.
Pensez à la tragédie que serait
la destruction de tout ce que les humains ont accompli.
Et il y a une autre raison d'y aller :
l'exploration est dans notre ADN.
Il y a deux millions d'années, les humains ont évolué en Afrique
et puis, lentement mais sûrement, se sont répandus sur la Terre entière
en explorant les régions sauvages au-delà de tout horizon.
Tout ça est en nous.
Et ce faisant, ils ont prospéré.
Certains des plus grandes avancées en civilisation et dans la technologie
ont pu se faire car nous avons exploré.
Oui, il y aurait beaucoup
de choses bien à faire avec l'argent dépensé pour établir une colonie sur Mars.
Et oui on devrait tous faire bien plus attention à notre planète-mère.
Et oui, je m'inquiète que l'on peut gâcher Mars comme nous avons gâché la Terre.
Mais réfléchissez un instant,
ce qu'on avait quand John F. Kennedy annonçait qu'un homme irait sur la lune.
Il a fait rêver toute une génération.
Pensez à l'excitation que procurera un atterrissage sur Mars.
Peut-être qu'alors, nous regarderons la Terre
et nous verrons un peuple parmi tant d'autres,
et peut-être qu'alors, nous regarderons la Terre,
alors que nous luttons pour survivre sur Mars,
et nous réaliserons combien la planète-mère est précieuse.
Permettez-moi de vous décrire l'aventure extraordinaire qui nous attend.
Mais d'abord,
quelques anecdotes fascinantes sur notre destination.
Cette image représente la vraie taille de Mars par rapport à la Terre.
Mars n'est pas notre planète-sœur.
Elle fait bien moins de la moitié de la Terre.
Mais malgré sa taille plus petite,
la surface de Mars sur laquelle on peut se tenir
équivaut à la surface de la Terre sur laquelle on peut se tenir,
car la plupart de la Terre est couverte d'eau.
L'atmosphère sur Mars est très fine,
100 fois plus légère que celle de la Terre,
et elle n'est pas respirable, composée de dioxyde de carbone à 96 pour cent.
Il fait très froid, là-bas.
La température moyenne est à moins 81 degrés,
bien que la température varie grandement.
Un jour sur Mars est presque aussi long que sur Terre,
en ajoutant environ 39 minutes.
Les saisons et les années sur Mars sont deux fois plus longues que sur Terre.
Et pour quiconque voudrait mettre des ailes et voler un jour,
la pesanteur sur Mars est bien moindre que sur Terre,
et c'est le genre de lieu
où on peut enjamber sa voiture au lieu d'en faire le tour.
Alors, comme vous voyez, Mars n'est pas exactement comme la Terre,
mais c'est, de tout notre système solaire, le lieu le plus habitable, outre la Terre.
Voilà le problème.
Mars est loin d'ici,
1 000 fois plus loin de nous que la lune.
La lune est à 384 400 km d'ici,
et il a fallu trois jours aux astronautes d'Apollo pour y arriver.
Mars est à 400 millions de km d'ici
et il nous faudra huit mois pour y arriver,
240 jours.
Et ça, c'est seulement si on part un jour bien précis,
à une heure très précise,
une fois tous les deux ans,
quand Mars et la Terre sont alignés parfaitement,
pour que la distance que la fusée ait à parcourir soit la plus courte.
240 jours, c'est un long moment à passer enfermé avec vos collègues dans une boîte.
Et par le passé, nous n'avons pas été très performants pour arriver sur Mars.
Nous et les Russes, les Européens, les Japonais,
les Chinois et les Indiens,
avons en fait envoyé 44 fusées là-bas,
dont l'immense majorité s'est soit loupée, soit écrasée.
Seul un tiers, environ, des missions vers Mars, ont été un succès.
On ne dispose pas à ce jour d'une fusée assez grande pour y aller.
Nous l'avions, autrefois, la fusée Saturn V.
Quelques Saturn Vs nous y auraient amené !
C’était la machine la plus magnifique jamais construite par les humains,
c’est cette fusée qui nous amené sur la lune.
Mais la dernière Saturn V a servi en 1973 pour lancer la station spatiale Skylab
et nous avons décidé de faire ce qu'on appelle la navette,
au lieu de continuer vers Mars après avoir atterri sur la Lune.
À présent, la plus grande fusée
ne fait que la moitié de ce qu'il faut pour aller sur Mars.
Donc, arriver à Mars ne sera pas facile.
Ceci soulève une question très intéressante.
Quand les premiers humains atterriront-ils là-bas ?
Certains experts pensent que si nous y arrivions d'ici 2050,
ce serait un grand exploit.
Aujourd'hui, la NASA pense pouvoir emmener des humains sur Mars d'ici 2040.
Peut-être est-ce possible.
Je crois qu'ils pourront mettre des humains dans son orbite vers 2035.
Mais franchement,
je ne pense pas qu'ils vont s'embêter à envoyer une fusée vers Mars en 2035,
parce que nous y serons déjà.
Nous allons atterrir sur Mars en 2027.
Et la raison à cela,
c'est cet homme, déterminé à accomplir ça.
Il s'appelle Elon Musk, il est le PDG de Tesla Motors et SpaceX.
Alors, il m'a confié que nous aurons atterri sur Mars d'ici 2025,
mais Elon Musk est plus optimiste que moi
et ce n'est pas rien...
donc je lui donne une marge de quelques années.
Toujours est-il...
vous devez vous demander,
cet homme pourra-t-il le faire d'ici 2025 ou 2027 ?
Bon, mettons une décennie avec Elon Musk en perspective.
Où en était-ce, il y a dix ans ?
Ceci est la Tesla Electrique automobile.
En 2005, beaucoup de gens dans l'industrie automobile disaient
que nous n'aurions pas de voiture électrique décente avant 50 ans.
Et ça, où était-ce ?
Voici la fusée Falcon 9 de SpaxeX
qui emporte six tonnes de provisions vers la Station spatiale internationale.
10 ans plus tôt,
SpaxeX n'avait pas lancé quoi que ce soit, pas une seule fusée où que ce soit.
Alors il me semble que c'est un pari sûr
que la personne qui révolutionne l'industrie automobile
en moins de 10 ans
et la personne qui a créé une entreprise de fusée entière en moins de 10 ans
nous amènera sur Mars d'ici 2027.
Alors, il faut que vous sachiez ceci :
les gouvernements et les robots ne contrôlent plus ce jeu.
Les entreprises privées bondissent dans l'espace
et elles se feront une joie de vous emmener sur Mars.
Et ça soulève une question très importante.
Peut-on vivre là-bas ?
La NASA ne sera peut-être pas en mesure de nous y emmener avant 2040,
ou peut-être qu'on y sera bien avant la NASA,
mais la NASA assume une lourde charge en déterminant comment vivre sur Mars.
Observons le problème de cette façon.
Pour vivre sur Terre,
il vous faut de la nourriture, de l'eau, un abri et des vêtements.
Et voici ce qu'il vous faut pour vivre sur Mars :
tous les éléments ci-dessus, plus de l'oxygène.
D'abord, regardons de plus près la chose la plus importante sur cette liste.
L'eau est la base de toute forme de vie, à notre connaissance,
et ce serait bien trop lourd pour nous d'en emmener depuis la Terre vers Mars
donc il faut trouver de l'eau si on veut que notre vie réussisse sur Mars.
Et si on regarde Mars, ça a l'air vraiment sec.
On dirait que la planète toute entière est un désert.
Mais il s'avère que ce n'est pas le cas.
Le sol lui-même contient jusqu'à 60 % d'eau.
Et un certain nombre de satellites qui tournent encore autour de Mars
nous ont montré... et au fait, c'est une vraie photo,
que beaucoup de cratères sur Mars contiennent une feuille d'eau glacée.
Pas mal comme endroit pour lancer une colonie.
Voici une prise de vue faite par le Phoenix Lander en 2008,
qui a creusé le sol, montrant de la glace juste sous la surface du sol,
ce qu'on voit en blanc, c'est de la glace.
Dans la deuxième photo,
prise quatre jours après la première photo,
on peut voir qu'une partie s'évapore.
Les satellites nous disent
aussi qu'il y a de grosses quantités d'eau souterraine sur Mars
ainsi que des glaciers.
En fait, si seulement l'eau glacée aux pôles de Mars fondait,
la plupart de la planète serait recouverte de 9 m d'eau.
Donc il y a beaucoup d'eau là-bas,
mais la plupart est glacée et sous le sol,
ça demande beaucoup d'énergie et d'efforts d'humains pour la récupérer.
Ceci est un appareil élaboré à l'Université de Washington
en 1998.
Grosso modo, il s'agit d'un déshumidificateur rudimentaire.
Et il se trouve que l'atmosphère sur Mars est souvent humide à 100 pour cent.
Donc cet appareil peut extraire toute l'eau dont les humains ont besoin
de l'atmosphère même sur Mars.
Ensuite, nous devons penser à ce que nous allons respirer.
Franchement, j'étais vraiment choqué
de découvrir que la NASA a déjà réglé ce problème.
Voici un scientifique au MIT, son nom est Michael Hecht.
Et il a mis au point cette machine, Moxie.
J'adore cette chose.
C'est une pile à combustible inversée, finalement,
qui aspire l'atmosphère martien et libère de l'oxygène.
Et vous devez vous souvenir que le CO2,
du dioxyde de carbone, qui constitue 96 % de l'atmosphère sur Mars,
le CO2 est constitué d'oxygène à 78 %.
Le prochain grand rover que la NASA envoie sur mars en 2020,
aura l'un de ces appareils à son bord,
et il sera capable de produire assez d'oxygène
pour maintenir une personne en vie indéfiniment.
Mais le secret derrière ça,
et c'est juste pour faire des tests,
mais le secret, c'est que cette chose a été conçue dès le début
pour que l'échelle de sa capacité s'ajuste au centuple.
Ensuite, que mangerons-nous ?
Nous aurons l'hydroponique pour cultiver de la nourriture,
mais nous ne pourrons pas faire pousser
plus de 15 à 20 % de notre nourriture,
du moins pas avant que l'eau ne coule à la surface de Mars,
et que nous ayons la probabilité et la capacité de planter des cultures.
En attendant, la plupart
de notre nourriture arrivera de la Terre,
et elle sera séchée.
Ensuite, il nous faut un abri.
Au début, on pourrait utiliser des bâtiments gonflables pressurisés
ainsi que les fusées elles-mêmes.
Mais ça ne fonctionne vraiment que pendant la journée.
Il y a trop de radiation solaire et trop de radiation des rayons cosmiques.
Donc nous devons vraiment vivre en souterrain.
Il se trouve que le sol sur Mars,
globalement, est parfait pour faire des briques.
Et la NASA a trouvé la solution pour ça aussi.
Ils vont balancer du plastique polymère dans les briques,
les fourrer dans un four à micro-ondes
et puis on pourra fabriquer des bâtiments avec des murs très épais.
Ou nous choisirons de vivre sous terre, dans des caves ou des tunnels de lave,
qui sont nombreux.
Et enfin, il y a les vêtements.
Sur Terre, nous avons des kilomètres d'atmosphère entassés sur nous,
ce qui crée 7 kg de pression sur nos corps à tout instant
et nous poussons constamment contre ça.
Sur Mars, il n'y a presque aucune pression atmosphérique.
Alors, Dava Newman,
une scientifique au MIT,
a créé cette combinaison spatiale élégante
pour nous protéger,
bloquer les radiations et nous tenir chaud.
Réfléchissons à ça pendant une minute,
la nourriture, l'abri, les habits, l'eau, l'oxygène...
nous pouvons le faire.
Vraiment.
Mais c'est encore un peu compliqué et assez difficile.
Ceci nous amène au prochain grand,
très grand pas,
vivre confortablement sur Mars.
Il faut terraformer la planète :
la rendre plus comme la Terre,
réaliser une réingénierie de toute une planète.
Ça paraît arrogant,
mais la vérité,
c'est que la technologie pour faire tout ce dont je vais vous parler existe déjà.
D'abord, il faut la réchauffer.
Mars est incroyablement froide car son atmosphère est très fine.
On peut trouver la réponse ici : au pôle sud et au pôle nord de Mars,
les deux étant couverts
d'une quantité incroyable de dioxyde de carbone,
de la glace sèche.
Quand on la réchauffe,
elle se sublime directement dans l'atmosphère
et épaissit l'atmosphère de la même manière que sur Terre.
Et comme nous le savons,
le CO2 est un gaz à effet de serre incroyablement puissant.
Ma méthode favorite pour faire ça, c'est d'ériger un voile solaire très large
et de faire le point,
il sert en gros de miroir
qui vise le pôle sud de Mars pour commencer.
Alors que la planète tourne, il chauffera toute cette glace sèche, il la sublimera
et elle partira dans l'atmosphère.
Ça ne prendra pas longtemps
pour que la température sur Mars
commence à monter, probablement moins de 20 ans.
À cet instant,
un jour parfait, à l'équateur,
au milieu de l'été sur Mars,
les températures peuvent atteindre 70 degrés,
mais ensuite, elles descendent à moins 100 la nuit.
(Rires)
Ce qu'on recherche, c'est un emballement de l'effet de serre,
une montée de température suffisante pour qu'une grosse quantité de la glace
sur Mars, et surtout la glace dans le sol, fonde.
Et la vraie magie opère.
Quand l'atmosphère s'épaissit, tout devient mieux.
Nous sommes mieux protégés des radiations,
plus d'atmosphère, ça veut dire plus que la planète se réchauffe,
alors on a de l'eau qui coule,
et ça rend la culture possible.
L'air reçoit encore plus de vapeur d'eau, pour un nouvel effet de serre puissant.
Il pleuvra et il neigera sur Mars.
Et avec une atmosphère plus épaisse, il y aura assez de pression
pour nous débarrasser de nos combinaisons.
2,5 kg de pression sont suffisants pour que nous survivions.
À terme, on se sentira sur Mars comme en Colombie-Britannique.
Il nous restera toujours le problème compliqué
de rendre l'atmosphère respirable
et franchement, ça pourrait prendre mille ans à accomplir.
Mais les humains sont très intelligents et s'adaptent incroyablement bien.
On ne peut savoir ce que notre technologie nous permettra d'accomplir à l'avenir,
ni ce qu'on peut faire avec nos propres corps.
En biologie, en ce moment-même,
nous sommes sur le point d'être en mesure de contrôler notre propre génétique,
ce que les gènes dans nos propres corps font
et assurément,
à terme, notre propre évolution.
Nous pourrions nous retrouver avec une espèce d'êtres humains sur Terre
légèrement différente de l'espèce d'êtres humains présente sur Mars.
Mais que feriez-vous là-bas ? Comment y vivre ?
Ce sera la même chose que sur Terre.
Quelqu'un ouvrira un restaurant,
quelqu'un fabriquera une fonderie de fer.
Quelqu'un fera des films documentaires sur Mars
et les vendra sur Terre.
Un idiot lancera une émission de télé-réalité.
(Rires)
Il y aura des entreprises de logiciel,
il y aura des hôtels, il y aura des bars.
Voici ce dont on est sûr :
ce sera l'événement le plus bouleversant de nos vies
et le plus excitant, à mon avis.
Demandez à n'importe quelle fille de 10 ans si elle veut aller sur Mars.
Les enfants qui sont actuellement à l'école primaire choisiront d'y vivre.
Vous souvenez-vous de quand des humains ont aluni ?
Quand c'est arrivé, les gens se sont regardés et ont dit :
« Si on peut faire ça, tout est possible. »
Que penseront-ils quand nous établirons une colonie sur Mars ?
Et plus important,
ça fera de nous une espèce qui explore et navigue dans l'espace.
Et ça signifie que les humains survivront, peu importe ce qui se passe sur Terre.
Nous ne serons jamais les derniers de notre espèce.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)